The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So.
I got the preparation
for finite elements.
Again we're in one
dimension, because that's
where you can see first and most
clearly how the system works.
So the system was, really,
to begin with the weak form
that I introduced last time.
The Galerkin idea
that I introduced just
at the very end of last
time, and that idea
is that instead of the
continuous differential
equations where--
Galerkin's idea
is how do you make it
discrete, and he'll
choose some trial functions.
Those are functions.
And some test function.
And I didn't get to
say, but I'll say now,
very often they're the same.
So very often the phis
are the same as the V's.
And probably they will be
in all my examples today.
And then what's new today is,
what choices would you make?
You have pretty wide choice,
but there are some natural ones
to start with.
And so that's
where we are today.
And then also the
other part of today
is how do we get from all that
preparation to the equations
that we actually solve.
The KU=F, where does
the K come from,
where does the F come from?
The F is going to come,
of course, somehow
from this right-hand
side and the K
is going to come
from the left side.
OK, so that's the
overall direction
if you want to know how
finite elements work,
that's the key line there.
And then here I've recalled
what the step was, here's
our differential equation.
And there's its weak form.
This is the weak form.
And let me put this in.
Here I've reproduced
what we reached
last time, the weak form.
That was the strong form
with its boundary conditions;
now we get the weak form
with its boundary conditions.
And the weak form
involves u, so it's
the boundary conditions
on u, the fixed ones,
that get used in the weak form.
The free ones don't
appear in the weak form,
but by the magic of
integration by parts,
the free ones will sort of
come out in a natural way.
But we have to build in the
essential, Dirichlet boundary
conditions like that
fixed right-hand end.
OK, and because I think of v as
a little movement away from u,
but my u's are all
fixed at the end,
therefore v has
to be fixed, too.
OK, so this is important.
But we haven't made
it down to Earth yet.
We were doing a lot
of ideas last time,
which are the center of
things, but now let's
get down to Earth.
And down to Earth really means,
what functions do we choose?
And then how do we
get the equation.
So that's the job today,
the principal job and this
is of course what
you would actually
code up to run a finite
element simulation.
You would make a decision
on these functions.
And let's start with
piecewise linear functions.
So a typical phi is
maybe centered at a node,
so it goes up and down.
So if that's node two,
let's number these nodes:
one, two, three, four, and five.
Well, that's five there but
I'm going to have, let's see.
What do I have here?
At a typical node,
two, my function
is zero except in the
intervals that touch node two.
So here's phi_2.
phi_2(x).
That's its graph.
It comes along, it's
piecewise linear up,
it's piecewise linear back
down, and it's zero again.
So that would be phi_2.
Then phi_1, there'll be a phi_1.
Like so, exactly similar.
The whole point is
keep the system simple.
That's what the finite
element idea is.
Use simple functions
for the phis.
And I'm taking them
also to be the test
function v. Keep those simple.
Now, what about
at the boundaries?
OK, well we've said our
functions have to be,
I'm doing free-fixed.
So fixed comes to zero there and
all my functions will do that.
But this end is
free, so watch this.
This is another, what
I'll call a half-hat.
If I call those hat
functions is that OK?
It makes a nice short word.
So these are hat functions.
And then a fuller description
would be piecewise linear,
but hat functions is clear.
OK, now notice I'm sticking
in here what I maybe
could call a half-hat.
Because my V's and
my phis, my functions
are not constrained
at that left-hand end.
That's free.
So there's a phi_1,
and there's a phi_0.
And a phi_3, and a phi_4.
So altogether, I'm
going to have five.
And I've started the
numbering at zero,
I guess it just happens.
So let's accept that.
So I'm going to
have five functions.
And they will also be
my five test functions.
So let me first think of
them as the trial functions.
Phi.
So what was the point
about trial functions?
The point about is, my
approximate, my finite element
solution U(x) is going to
be a combination of those.
Some U_0, times
the phi_0 function,
up to U_4 times
the phi_4 function.
And these are my unknowns.
U_0, U_1, those numbers.
I have five unknowns.
And I'm using hat functions.
So I should, really, why
don't I draw a graph of U(x).
So I don't need the
words piecewise linear.
You see, I have a kind
of space of functions.
My functions are all,
my approximations
are combinations of these
fixed basis functions.
You could call these phis, trial
functions, basis functions,
you're always choosing,
in applied math,
a bunch of functions whose
combinations are going to be,
is what you're
going to work with.
And here I'm making
them hat functions.
OK, so what does a combination
of those guys look like?
I'll even erase the
word hat functions;
we won't forget that.
So what would a
combination of-- Here's
the same interval zero, one,
with the same mesh, one, two,
three, four guys inside.
What would-- It just helps
the visualization to see.
If I combine these guys, so
those were, despite the way
it might look, that's
one separate function.
Two, three, four and five.
And now suppose I
take a combination.
What kind of a
function do I get?
How would you describe this,
a combination like this?
Of those five guys?
What will it look like?
Between every node it will
be a straight line, right?
Because all these guys are
straight, between those.
So a typical function
will start at what?
This height will be
U_0, because, well
let me draw a few things.
OK, so I'll put U_0 a
little higher because I
want to end up down at zero.
So that might be the height U_0,
and U_1 might be pretty close.
U_2 might be coming down a bit.
Coming down a bit,
coming down a bit.
And ending at zero.
So those were meant
to be corners.
That wasn't a very good bit.
There, OK.
It wasn't meant to be, yeah.
So that height is U_0.
Now, notice why?
Why is that?
Why is the coefficient
of phi_0 exactly
the height, the
displacement, at zero?
Because all the
other phis are zero.
All the other phis are
zero at this point.
Only this guy's coming in.
So we'll only see in
this, at this point,
see, even phi_1 has
dropped to zero.
So we're only going to
see phi_0 times U_0.
So, I should have said, we take
all these heights to be one.
Height is one.
Course it doesn't matter
because we're multiplying
by u's, but so let's settle.
They all have heights one.
And this is sort of a key part
of the finite element idea.
You see, Galerkin,
when he created
just two or three
functions phi, he
tried to follow
the exact solution.
He had an idea in his mind what
the solution to the problem
will be.
And he wanted to take two
or three functions that
would get him close to it.
Here we choose the
functions, they're
in the finite element
library before we even
know what the equation is,
or the boundary conditions.
These functions are like,
the hat function choice.
And they have this beautiful
sort of a connect to nodes.
In a way where-- In fact, I
got involved in finite elements
in the first place
just to understand
what's the difference
between finite elements
and finite differences.
Because the finite
elements, as you'll see,
are associated with nodes.
phi_1 is the only guy
that's not zero at node one.
And therefore, what
will this height be?
What's that height?
So that maybe comes
down a little.
What's this height?
U_1.
It's the coefficient of phi_1,
because phi_1 is sitting there.
And all the other
phis are zero there,
so this height is really U_1.
And U_2, and U_3, and
U_4, and U_5 is zero.
So that was U_1, U_2, and so on.
What I'm saying is, and
we'll see it happen,
is that this KU=F equation
that we finally get to is going
to look very like a finite
difference equation.
But it's coming from
this different direction.
And this way allows
many more possibilities,
gets things sort of
more naturally right.
It takes less-- With the
finite difference equation,
we had to go in there and
decide what it should be.
With finite elements, our
decision is just the phis.
Once we've decided
the phis, Galerkin
tells us what the equation is.
And we'll get to the
KU=F, what it is.
But here I'm getting you to see
what our approximate solution
can look like.
And this beautiful fact that
the coefficients in here
have a physical meaning.
They're actually
the displacements
at the nodes for these
simple functions.
OK.
You got a picture of what
the trial functions are,
some people would think about
the functions as these guys.
Other people might think of
this picture, the combinations.
So those are the
individual basis functions.
That's a typical combination
of the typical one.
OK, so we're looking for
an equation for these U's.
Five equations, of course.
Because we've got five U's.
So that's my final step here.
What are the five
equations for the five U's.
And those are the equations
that I'm going to call KU=F. OK.
So here's now a critical moment.
Where do the
equations come from?
Well, the equations
come from the weak form.
So I take the weak form.
And in for u, for u here,
I guess it's just there.
I put this.
I put capital U.
So can I just copy,
this is the weak form for
before we've made it discrete.
Before we've chosen n phis.
OK, now let's choose the
n phis, so now this'll
be the weak form.
Again, the weak
form with Galerkin.
After the decision.
So it'll be the integral,
from zero to one,
of this c(x), whatever it is.
Times the U(x)-- sorry, times
the dU/dx, right? dU/dx,
so what is dU/dx?
Oh, you have to pay attention.
This was a true solution.
Little u.
But now this is
where I'm working.
I'm working with capital U. So
instead of the d little u dx,
it's d capital U dx.
Maybe I'll put it in
there. d capital U dx.
And then I'll put
down here what it is.
What is it?
It's U_0*phi_0, can I use
prime just to-- Or d phi_0/dx,
whatever?
Can I use prime for derivative?
Just save a little space.
So this is the
derivative of my guy.
U_1*phi_1'(x), up
to whatever it was.
U_4*phi_4'(x).
That's what that term is.
And that multiplies dv/dx.
Where v is, here v
is any test function.
Any test function, only
required to have v(1)=0.
But now, I'm going discrete.
So instead of any test function,
I'll use these five functions.
So I've got five functions.
The phis are the same
as the V's, then.
V_1, V_2, V_3 and V_4.
Same guys.
So now I'll put in
dV, can I say dV_i/dx?
And on the right hand side I
have the integral from zero
to one of f(x)*V_i(x)dx, i is
zero, one, two, three, or four.
I'm testing against five V's.
So I have this equation
for five different V's.
So i equals zero,
one, two, three, four,
gives me my five equations.
Here are my five unknowns.
This is my five by five system.
Let me just step back a minute
so you see what happened there.
So what do you have to do?
You chose the basis functions,
the phis and the V's.
Then you just plug into the
weak form, you plug in dU/dx,
is coming from there.
So this is dU/dx.
You have to plug dV/dx, you
have to do the integrals.
You have to do the
integrals, that's
something we didn't have
in finite differences.
Finite elements involves
doing the integrals, left side
and right-hand side.
OK, so, and here we have five
different integrals to do.
We have f(x) times
each V. This will be,
this number will be F_i.
So my F vector is going to
be an F_0, F_1, down to F_4.
The five guys that I get
from these five integrals.
Alright.
And the K matrix is
sitting here somewhere.
That's the last thing,
that's the final thing,
is to see what is the K matrix.
Which is coming.
This is somehow K's times
U's are sitting here.
F's are sitting over there.
So it may be good to
see the F's first.
So do you see this now?
We made the choices,
then what's our job?
Our next job is to do
all the integrations.
Integrate my function against V.
Let's make the natural
first example, let f be one.
First example, let f be one.
All right.
So if f is one, I'm going
to find the system KU=F.
So if I know f(x) is one, then
I have everything I need to find
these numbers.
OK, actually we can
probably do those by,
you can probably tell
me what they are.
If f(x) is one, now.
So this is example one.
f(x) is a constant.
One we have solved before.
What's the integral of V_0?
Right, that's what I have to do.
What's the integral of
this, f(x) being one,
I'm just asking, I
just have V_0(x)?
The integral of V_0(x),
and let me again draw V_0,
which is phi_0.
It's a half hat and then
it goes along at zero.
What's the integral
of that function?
One, yeah.
How do I think
about that integral?
It's the area of the triangle.
It's the area.
That's what an integral
is, it's the area.
So the area is, I've
got delta x there.
Right, delta x as the base.
One as the height, and
you see the formula
for the area of a triangle, it's
got a half in there somewhere,
right?
A half.
OK, can I factor
out the delta x?
Because the delta x
is going to come in.
I think there's a half there.
And then what about F_1?
What's the integral of this
times V_1(x), the next V?
It's the area under
this dashed function.
Which is now the basis 2
delta x, so I get a one.
Is that right?
I get a one, one, one, one.
OK, so that was obviously
not too tough, right?
That was straightforward
and notice something.
Even here, in fact,
we see it here.
I don't know if you
remember about that half.
Do you remember something about
when we did finite differences
and we had a free boundary?
And we lost an order of accuracy
if we didn't do it right?
Do you remember that?
At the fixed boundary
we were fine,
but with finite differences
at a free boundary,
where I was using the
matrix T. With one,
minus one at the top row, I
lost an order of accuracy.
Unless I made some change
on the right-hand side.
Look what's happening.
The finite element method
is making the change for me
on the right hand side.
So the finite element method
is going to automatically keep
the second order accuracy.
Keep the second order accuracy.
So that's a key point.
That these piecewise
linear functions
are associated with
second order accuracy.
Later we'll move
up to parabolas,
to cubics; that will move
up the order of accuracy
in a nice way.
Where with finite
differences we would have
had to create new finite
difference formulas.
Our minus one, two,
minus one formula,
that was good for
second order accuracy.
Then we would have
to figure out,
in the quiz had
partly started it,
what if there's a c(x)
in there, what do you do?
Finite differences, there's
more thinking involved.
Finite elements is like
just press the button.
Well, there's a little more
to it than that of course,
because it's taking
a full lecture.
But in the end it's more
systematic, you could say.
So that's the F. Now
are you ready for the K?
So this is the key part, OK?
So you have to can get
this thing to simplify.
So what am I looking for here?
This whole left-hand
side should be K times U.
So I'm looking to see what
multiplies-- I'm looking
to make sense out of this.
What's the first equation?
Right, so the first equation or
the zeroth equation, I guess.
The zeroth equation,
the one that'll
run along and have
this right-hand side,
the zeroth equation is the
equation when i is zero.
It's the equation that
comes from testing
our weak form for V_0.
For that particular form.
Maybe I'll just start
over on this board.
Then I can write a
formula, but I'd rather you
see how it comes.
So I'm looking at equation zero.
So take i=0.
So I have my left side
is my integral, of c(x).
Times this combination that
I wrote, U_0*phi_0' plus...
U_4*phi_4', times
dV_0/dx*dx equal,
and on the right side
is where I got the F_0,
which I already figured out
to be delta x times a half.
It's the left side that
I'm worrying about.
OK, you see what's
happening here?
This is some matrix.
Its zeroth row is what we're
finding -- multiplying U_0,
U_1, U_2, U_3, and U_4
-- equaling the F vector.
I'm supposed to be getting
the first row of the matrix,
the top row of the matrix,
from the top V. OK,
so let's just do these.
We've got integrals to do again.
Alright, what is dV_0/dx?
Do you see?
Let me just see?
What number is going in here?
What number is going in there?
Yeah, if we see
that we're golden.
What number is going in there?
That's the thing that multiplies
U_0 in the first row that
means I should use V_0, so this
is the point, this is K_00.
And what's its formula?
You realize I'm starting
the count at zero
because all these
counts-- So what is K_00?
It's an integral.
Of what? c(x), good.
Times this guy, because it's
multiplying, times this guy,
V_0', dx.
That's what you have to do.
That's what you have
to do. c(x) times
phi', it's phi_0', that's
what would sit there.
And maybe, well, let's
figure that one, shall we?
I have to know c(x), right,
that's part of the problem.
What would you like
me to choose for c(x)?
One.
Thank you.
I'll choose one.
Let this be one.
Or I could make it
capital C and you
would see a capital C appearing
everywhere, but let's make it
one.
So what are we doing now?
What's our equation?
Our right-hand side is
one, our c(x) is one,
our equation has
reduced to -u''=1.
The first equation
in the course.
So we're back to September
the 3rd or whatever it was.
But doing it now
by finite elements.
OK, so let c(x) be one and
tell me what this integral is.
So c(x) is now, we're
taking-- In our problem,
we're supposing it's one.
Let me just say:
Suppose it's function.
Then we have lots of integrals
to do involving that function.
And we might not do them
exactly, that would be alright.
It's certainly totally OK to
do the integrals approximately,
because we're doing
everything else approximately.
So we just have to be sure
that we do the integrals
with sufficient accuracy so
that we don't lose accuracy
in the integrals.
Of course, with
a one we're going
to do the integral exactly.
But if c(x) was some
variable function,
I wouldn't have
to do it exactly,
I would just have to do
it with enough accuracy
so that I don't
lose extra accuracy
beyond what I'm losing in the
whole Galerkin approximation.
OK, ready for that number.
What number comes out of that?
phi_0', let's graph phi_0'.
And of course it's the
same as V_0', so can I
put a little graph here?
Here is zero to one, and
I'm going to graph phi_0'.
So what's phi_0'?
Oh, it's negative, isn't it?
My little graph
isn't going to work.
I didn't leave enough room.
It's negative.
So I'll just write it in words.
It's the same as
V_0', and what is it?
Tell me what it is, what's the
derivative of that function?
It's what?
Negative one.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, it's going to have
a certain value, yeah.
You can tell me what it is
beyond that point real fast.
So it's something up to
delta-- So what is the slope?
What's that slope
there, of phi_0?
It's not negative one, because
remember, what's the base here?
That's not the point
one, I'm sorry.
All these were delta x's.
Those were just
numbering the nodes.
But the actual length
scale is the delta x scale.
So now tell me what it is.
The derivative is negative
one over delta x, right?
It dropped by one when it
went across by delta x.
And this is only up to node one.
Up to delta x and
then zero afterwards.
This is a key point.
That all our
functions are local.
Our functions are local.
What does that mean?
You can tell me what am I
going to get when I integrate,
for example, when later
on I might be integrating
phi_1' against V_4'.
What's the answer?
This is the key point.
Later, when I'm looking
for the one, four entry,
when I'm looking there,
I'm going to do an integral
of phi_1'.
I'll erase for a moment
and do this in my head.
When I integrate
phi_1' against V_4'.
Maybe it's the fourth row.
And the first guy over, maybe
it's this guy I'm doing.
Doesn't matter a whole lot.
Because the answer is,
when I integrate phi_1'
against V_4' just, it's
nice to get the easy ones.
It's zero.
Why is it zero?
Why is the integral of
phi_1' against V_4' zero?
Because these phis are local.
phi_1' is only non-zero here.
V_4' is only non-zero over here.
The two don't overlap.
Anywhere the one is not
zero, the other is zero.
So that's a zero there.
In fact, our overlaps, I'm just
sort of looking ahead here.
Our overlaps, a phi
overlaps itself, of course.
And its right-hand neighbor
and its left-hand neighbor.
But nobody two or
three or more away.
I think our K, all our integrals
are going to be zero outside,
we'll have another
tri-diagonal matrix.
We're going to have
zeroes all here.
And we'll only have
entries of phi against V
when they're either the
same or just differ by one.
So we'll only have
three diagonals.
OK, we were about to find
out what that number is.
So the slope of this is
minus one over delta x,
and that's-- I'm sorry, let
me go back to zero, zero.
OK.
This is what we're keeping
our fingers crossed for.
What's that number?
So I have this thing,
actually is it just squared?
And that's the slope.
And then the phi and the
V I'm choosing the same,
so that's the slope again.
I think I'm just
getting one over delta
x squared for that times
that times the one.
So what's K_00?
One over delta x.
Where'd the delta x come from?
Because we're only integrating
over, it looks like zero to one
but they're all zero.
We're really only
integrating, the only reality
was out to node one.
Out to delta x.
You see that the number there,
the number here on the diagonal
is one over delta x.
OK, how about doing K_11 for me?
So again, now these guys
will be the same guys.
It's a square.
No it's the integral phi_1'
against V_1', they're the same.
And what is phi_1', which
is the same as V_1'?
What's the derivative now?
It's, ah.
What's the slope
of this function?
It goes up and goes
back down, right?
I have a plus part,
so the slope going up
is the one over delta x.
And then the slope coming down
is minus one over delta x.
So this was up to
delta x and then
to two delta x, and then zero.
That's a much more
typical thing,
the slope goes the
function, the hat function
goes up to the top of the hat.
Back down.
The slope up and the
slope down are easy.
And now the integral's easy.
So I'm just squaring,
well, when I square it,
this squared is the one
over delta x squared.
This is the same, because
the minus will get squared.
So what's K_11?
What's K_11 now?
Have you got K_11 in your head?
This is one over
delta x squared.
And now what is the integral?
Two over delta x.
Because now we're integrating
from zero to two delta x,
because that's where my
functions are going out
from zero to node two.
If the function's numbered one.
So it's two delta
x times this; I
think we get a two over
delta x on that diagonal.
Would you care to guess
the rest of the diagonal?
Yes, you tell me what's
K_22 and K_33 and K_44?
They're all the same.
We're just shifting over.
So two over delta
x goes down there.
Alright, one more to do.
One more integral to do.
This next guy.
So can you tell me what
do I get now for K_01?
K_01, so now this is the
case where I'm in row zero,
so this should be V_0, because
that tells me the row I'm in.
But phi_1.
What happens when I integrate,
just see the picture here.
Let me just draw it small.
phi_1', so let me draw phi_1.
And V_0.
OK.
But it's the
derivatives that I want.
It's the slopes that I want, OK?
So what do I get
from here on out?
Zero, because this
guy only got to there.
That's the half hat, the
first guy stopped at delta x.
So whatever is happening here is
going to be multiplied by zero.
So it's just here.
One delta x interval
for this one.
They just overlap in
one interval, of course.
This guy and its neighbor
only overlap in one interval.
And what's the deal
about the two slopes?
They're opposite.
One's coming down,
one's going up.
But the slopes are
one over delta x
and minus one over delta x.
Do you see what's
happening here?
I'm integrating.
Here I have a slope
of one over delta x,
and here I have a slope
of minus one over delta x,
so I should multiply those.
Minus one over delta x squared,
integrate, what goes in K_01?
What's that number?
It's that times that
integrated, but now the integral
is only going
really out to delta
x because basically I'm
just stopping there.
So-- But there's a minus now.
Because it's not the square.
It's this times its neighbor.
One's going up, and
one's going down.
So it's delta x
squared, and then
the length of the interval, this
is a minus one over delta x.
Would you care to guess
the rest of this matrix?
What's the rest
of that diagonal,
above the main diagonal?
It's all the same.
That stays the same,
because when I do phi_2*V_1,
my picture is just
like shifted over.
But I still have one coming
down, and one going up.
When I do phi_3*V_2, same thing.
And if I do phi_1*V_2,
it'll be the same.
I'm going to get this
minus one over delta
x all the way on
that diagonal, also.
Symmetry.
It's going to come
out symmetric.
Actually, since
the course started
by speaking about
properties of matrices,
let me just say K is
going to turn out to be
symmetric positive definite.
And what's more,
for this example
we recognize K completely.
You will say: Why did you take
so long to get to this result?
K is the one over delta x
part times, what's the matrix?
It's T. It's T. So it's one,
minus one, minus one, two,
minus one, minus one, two, minus
one, minus one, two, minus one,
and I guess we had five of them.
Oh, but nobody there, right?
That's not there.
That fixed-- Why do we
not have a minus one?
Because we've got no,
there isn't a six.
That would be column-- We've
got one, two, three, four,
five columns; there's
no U_5, there's no V_5,
we've got them all.
And the F, so that-- So KU, this
thing multiplies U_0 to U_4,
to U_4, and it
produces F, which is
one over delta, which is what?
Oh, delta x is in
the numerator, right.
Times a half, one,
one, one and one.
That is the finite
element system KU=F.
For this simple problem.
It's exactly what
finite differences did.
So you can see why my first
introduction to finite elements
was with the question:
what's the difference?
The finite element community
at that point, this
was like the golden
age of finite elements,
all this was just
beginning to be created.
These elements were being used.
Especially in civil and
structural engineering,
that's where a lot of the
earliest papers came out of.
And then, in a model problem
it didn't look anything new.
It looked like our original
finite difference matrix.
But there were some new things.
First, there was this new 1/2,
that we hadn't particularly
noticed with finite differences.
We, we could catch onto that.
Here's a minor difference.
You notice that the
delta x is-- Strictly
speaking the delta
x is up here then,
but when I divide
by delta x then I'm
back to the finite difference.
I have the one over
delta x squared,
it looks like finite
differences again.
So everything looks the same.
But, of course, if c(x) isn't
one or if f(x) isn't one,
oh yeah.
If c(x) isn't one then
I've got integrals to do.
I would approximate those.
And I could then come out
with something that would
look like a finite differences.
Let me take our other
favorite model problem.
What would be the F if,
yeah, here's a question.
What would be the right
side if my vector,
instead of being one, what's
my other favorite choice?
Delta.
So I take delta at x minus, let
me take delta at x minus 1/4,
first.
Suppose that's my f.
Then I've got to
change all these guys.
And what would they be?
What would be the
new right-hand side
when I have this point load?
I have to go back to
the integrals, right?
I have to go back to these guys.
These integrals,
with that new f,
this is now delta of x minus
a 1/4, times each V, times dx.
I have to integrate
delta of x minus 1/4
against every hat function.
And see what it equals?
And what will I get?
You're going to
tell me right away.
What are those integrals?
That's a point load at node one.
Times the V integrated
over the whole thing.
What do I get?
I get a one, yeah.
That integral is going to pick
out the value at a quarter.
Right, that's what the
delta function does,
the spike is at a quarter.
Has area one, so it picks
out the V_i at a quarter.
V_i at a quarter will be?
One for the-- I think we
get a [0, 1, 0, 0, 0].
Again a little bit what
our finite differences
suggested that we should do.
Alright, here's one
final one for today.
Suppose the delta
function is not at a node.
Suppose it's at 3/8.
Or it could be at
any point a, but let
me just take a typical, a
special one where I can do it.
Suppose the load is at 3/8.
What do I get for
the integrals now?
So now, it's delta
of x minus 3/8.
The spike is at this point here.
That's where delta is
now, spiking at 3/8.
Is that right?
We had 1/5, tell me what-- oh,
I should have had 1/5 before,
sorry.
Change that on the videotape.
All those 1/4s were--
That 1/4 was 1/5,
and now what do I want?
Three?
I wanted to take a nice
one that was halfway.
I just forgot what halfway was.
Where is halfway there?
3/10 now for delta.
So that was-- Before I
had it for when delta.
So previously was
delta at x minus 1/5
and now delta at x minus
3/10, what's the F now?
What's the F now?
So the spike is right in the
middle between one and two.
What's do those
integrals come out to be?
If I integrate delta function
times the different hats,
what do I get?
What do I get, yeah.
I get a zero for this
first guy because it
didn't touch the half hat.
And then what do I get there?
Half.
And what do I get
at the next one?
Half again.
And then the other
guys it doesn't touch.
You see, it
automatically does it.
Does those smart things.
It automatically makes
the smart choice.
And if the spike was
at a, at any point a,
then at that typical
point a wherever it is,
like there, spike
could be there.
Then I would have, what would
I have if the spike was there?
I'd have a little bit of
phi_3, and a big bit of phi_4.
And the two parts
would add to one.
It would take the
right proportion.
It would be the proportion,
by however much this spike was
near there, it would give
that extra weight to phi_4.
OK.
So there is the
finite element method.
It produced something that you
might say, oh, we knew that.
But you've got to see that it
deals automatically with c(x),
it deals automatically
with f(x),
with the free boundary.
You see, the solution
there is going
to take sort of a balance,
a pretty close balance,
of this half hat with this one,
and the solution will actually
be a pretty close to free.
It'll be pretty close to having
the right zero slope there.
OK, good.